[Musique]
c'est un peu étrange de me présenter à
vous ici dans la pénombre
je vois peine vous me voyez à peine vous
êtes toujours dans la pénombre je vous
vois toujours à peine
vous me voyez beaucoup mieux sûrement
c'est pas la technique je ne vous voit
de nouveau très mal
vous voyez un peu et l'importance de la
lumière c'est lorsque quelque chose nous
manque que l'on comprend son importance
la lumière et pourtant cette lumière
vous n'y avais pas prêté grande
attention
depuis tout à l'heure en temps sud est
et c'est beau ça en temps cet été en
temps si tu étais le feu j ai chandelier
a l'air de l'électricité c'est une lampe
paf filaments une lampe incandescente
peut-être un tube néon celui des
cuisines de nos grands-mères peut-être
chez vous encore de sa grand-mère ou des
chambres d'hôpitaux qu'on visite ou pas
donc cette lumière c'est la vie c'est
très important
en revanche tout à l'heure lorsque ils
ont encore lorsque cette lumière s'est
allumée cette étape j'ai vu là-bas
madame je crois monsieur là bas sur le
téléphone le smartphone parce que
connecter cette lumière s'éteignait
s'allumer en revanche notre connexion
elle ne s'est pas éteinte nous sommes
restés connectés et gmail du message
quelque chose donc notre environnement
électromagnétique
et quand même un peu présent est ce
qu'on le contrôle j'en suis pas sûr
effectivement j'ai 55 ans j'ai 55 ans et
il y a dix ans encore 10 ans a même à
peine cet outil ne nous servait qu'à
téléphoner nous décidions je décidé
d'être dérangés ou pas c'était un bref
instant
c'était quelques minutes peut-être
mesdames de longues minutes donc mais
aujourd'hui c'est permanent
cette connexion perdure cette connexion
ne cesse jamais nous sommes en
permanence connectés c'est effectivement
souvent le wi-fi le wifi et le wifi je
peux vous en parler ça fait 25 ans que
je baigne dans ce monde du wifi il a
démarré il a démarré c'était une
technologie on l'appelait technologie
sans fil technologies radiofréquences ça
servait à suivre les containers dans les
ports ici à marseille un peu partout en
france un peu partout dans le monde
suivre des containers dans les ports et
puis suivre des marchandises dans les
entrepôts et puis suivre les
marchandises dans les magasins et puis
ce wii fit est arrivée dans les magasins
dans les centres commerciaux est arrivé
c'était les hotspots wifi et puis ce wii
fit qui est arrivé à la maison donc ce
wifi partout toujours ses ondes
électromagnétiques que l'on maîtrise
assez peu je crois que vous maîtrisez
peut-être
comme je vous le disais j'ai cette
expérience et je sais que ça peut être
envahissant pour le moins d'ailleurs le
législateur l'a compris je ne sais pas
si vous en êtes informés la loi abaisse
est une loi en france qui interdit le
wifi pour la petite enfance à savoir les
enfants de moins de 3 ans ne doivent pas
être exposés au wifi dans les zones qui
les accueillent les autres grand public
qui les accueillent une crèche en
l'occurrence d'ailleurs aussi le
législateur c'est cette semaine là on
est vraiment sur quelque chose de
procréer cette semaine le législateur
qui décide que le téléphone est exclu
c'est pas seulement dans les crèches
mais c'est aussi dans le primaire c'est
aussi jusqu'au collège donc
réfléchissons à cet envahissement de ce
smartphone ce smartphone qui fait
beaucoup plus que le téléphone
maintenant puisque je reçois des
notifications gély mes mails je partage
tout ce que je fais sur les réseaux
sociaux mes amis enfin mes amis ceux qui
ont un jour cliquez ceux qui m'ont un
jour like et sont devenus mes amis est
donc maintenant je sais qu'ils sont
celui ci à paris celui ci a marseille
une photo sur le vieux port à marseille
qui partagent immédiatement à new york à
milan sur les pentes neigeuses à la
finale d'un de roland garros parce que
je dois le savoir tout de suite tout de
suite tout de suite je reste connecté en
permanence et donc mais mon fils c'est
pareil c'est même pire
mon fils à la maison est en permanence
dont je je le vois par rapport à mes
autres enfants mon petit dernier est en
permanence sur son smartphone sur son
téléphone sur sa tablette
regardez je ne sais quoi les réseaux
sociaux une vidéo une vidéo qui trouvent
eux spécialement intéressante
wifi toujours plus présent toujours plus
envahissant
pour lui c'est clair le wifi c'est la
vie cette lumière si importante
cet éclairage qui pourrait être de
l'éclairage led
cette petite led c'est une véritable
révolution la révolution l'aide
cette led elle peut varier en intensité
et en couleurs
donc on peut reproduire de façon
quasiment ont reproduit de façon
artificielle l'éclairage naturel
cet éclairage led devient circadien à
savoir faible et d'où le matin pour nous
réveiller en quelque sorte intense blanc
fort le midi le zénith qui s'apaise
en fin de journée pour redevenir
chaleureux vous voyez ces jolies
couleurs le soir le beau si les rosso
d'icera belle au tempo 6 pers a donc
cette douce lumière du soir qui nous
garantit un endormissement et qui nous
favorisent parce que c'est extrêmement
important ce rythme circadien la preuve
le prix nobel de médecine a été attribué
à des chronobiologistes qui
travaillaient sur le rythme circadien
l'importance de cette lumière et cette
lumière led
elle permet bien d'autres choses elle
permet aussi
effectivement cette connexion cette
lumière led scintille elle scintille
elle s'éteint et salue des milliers de
fois par seconde des dizaines de
milliers de fois par seconde des
centaines de milliers de fois par
seconde
qu'est ce que c'est mais ce sont des uns
des uns et des zéros des uns et des
héros c'est le code binaire c'est le b à
ba de l'informatique de l' échange de
données de la collection c'est la
possibilité
deux véhicules et des beats débite des
byte débit thd et mike se désole t d
opter des méga ôter des gigaoctets donc
la possibilité de se connecter le lit
fit le lit free pour light fidelity le
pendant du wi fi pour wireless fidelity
mais sans ondes radios donc plus cet
environnement puisque c'est long deux
lumineuse c'est cette lumière qui nous
donne la connexion vous avez peut-être
été intrigué par cette petite chose donc
qui me permet de connecter mon
ordinateur
si ma lumière est connecté je connecte
mon ordinateur je reçois la lumière je
renvoie la lumière je veux connaître
demain sera intégrée dans nos
smartphones dans nos tablettes mais sans
ondes radio donc la possibilité de se
protéger en quelque sorte de ce méfait
que qu'est cet environnement
électromagnétique qu'on ne maîtrise pas
c'est aussi la possibilité de sécuriser
l'information parce qu'aujourd'hui aussi
sympathique soit-il j'ai pas forcément
envie de partager mon wifi avec mes
voisins
or vous savez aujourd'hui vous captez le
wifi de vos voisins pas le lit fille
c'est donc un enjeu de santé pendant
d'électrodes magnétique mais aussi un
enjeu de sécurité
une actualité aujourd'hui la protection
des données donc nous protégeons mieux
nos données avec ce l'ifi et donc la
sécurité la santé
donc on protège ces données mais c'est
aussi la possibilité pour mon enfant à
mon fils de 15 ans il a 15 ans le petit
dernier c'est le chéri tu as éteinte
chez les enfants voulaient dire
effectivement le temps de la nuit
devient le temps du sommeil aujourd'hui
vous avez toutes et tous tout et tout
pardon cette expérience des enfants
beaucoup trop tard souvent très tard
trop tard dans la nuit connecter à leurs
écrans bleus demain avec le wifi je
coupe le la lumière je coupe le lit fit
donc le temps de la nuit redevient le
temps du sommeil je reprends contrôle de
ma connexion
nous reprenons contrôle de notre
connexion avec ce l'ifi alors les
technologies quelquefois viennent
corriger les excès ou les méfaits des
autres c'est peut-être un peu le cas de
ceux l'ifi par rapport au wifi
cela permet de redevenir des
utilisateurs des consommateurs éclairés
de notre connexion
alors maintenant en conclusion en
quelque sorte
j'espère que lorsque vous sortirez de la
salle vous penserez peut-être à cette
intervention
lorsque vous rallume revo portable merci
[Applaudissements]